des fumées pendant les grandes fêtes et
tout ça mais jamais rien même pas rompu
comme on provoque surtout quand on fume
après on commence à avoir mal au ventre
il vaut mieux pas fumer vous dire j'ai
beaucoup tout sauter votre première
cigarette c'est parce que je savais pas
comment fait exactement
on s'était je sais pas j'avais 5 ans par
mois c'était pendant les vacances on
était là juste en angleterre mais tu as
quel âge 14 ans lors d'une réunion de
famille et matin tu as essayé de me
faire fumer je devais avoir 7 8 ans et
malheureusement j'ai fumé à l'envers ce
qui m'a dégoûté un peu mais par la suite
j'ai fumé peut-être une cigarette ou
deux points devant le pour faire un peu
comme les copains quoi tu étais dans le
groupe c'est venu comme ça parce que
tout le temps m'ont proposé en début je
refusais puis à la fin j'ai quand même
fini par accepter de prendre une
cigarette mais c'était juste comme ça
pour m'intégrer au groupe et enfin enfin
comme les autres quoi jeter dans un
groupe où l'angleterre
non non ce qu'il faut mais pas été
considérées comme des petits pains
ou alors je me suis décidé bon bah on va
faire une cigarette ou deux qu'on voit
des petits garçons fumée des garçons 2
7e
on est dans la rue cigarette au bec bon
moi je pense que c'est un peu pour la
frime pour faire bien pour faire comme
tout le monde
puis il fume ça c'est la mode il fume
n'importe quoi ou plusieurs d'entre vous
m'ont dit tout à l'heure que chez eux il
n'y avait aucune interdiction on vous
laisse fumer si vous
les bruits on raisonnablement et pour
l'instant il faut quand même ça se
laisse tomber mais ils disent qu'il faut
quand même se réserver nos bas du rebond
on la soumet mon père mon cas d'ipo
spécialement des forces modérées et
maman elle permet une cigarette par
dimanche mais il ya même des rouges
l'oubli je voudrais pour commencer parce
que ça sert à rien consent à s'abîmer au
cou il n'est qu'ils fument plus calmé et
puis hélas ils sont calmes et sur le
coup il faut d'après ce encore plus
excité que qu'auparavant déjà je trouve
que fumer jeune c'est presque sûr qu on
fumera encore plus tard parce que si on
fume à 12 à 12 ans déjà on sent un petit
malaise si un film à 14 ans on
ressentira moins donc on dira bon peuple
grandit plus le malaise semble a donc à
des contrats que vers les 18 ans et on
retrouvera sa fin plus mal par ap
ça serait presque pas mal par parlera
pas qu'on avait 12 ans si on commence à
partir de 14 ans après ça devient une
habitude et puis on peu puissant pour
s'en défaire j'aimerais j'aimerais pas à
fumer parce que c'est si c'est pour
terminer ma vie avec des années - ça
vaut pas le coup je crois que fait râler
je préfère faire du sport encore plus
épais ne pas ne pas fumer et on vous
interdit l'alcool on en est ce qu'il ya
une différence
le fait et le dimanche on m'autorise
toujours non
mon quart de verdun
parce que quand tu trouves que c'est
plus naturel dans l'alcool on a des
shows scène de par exemple je ne parle
que du vin par exemple on a le raisin
d'accord on a un petit un petit
conservateur patients qui comme ça va tu
as pas si c'est vraiment aux
manifestations mais s'est atténué si
atténué par quelque chose s'est atténuée
par la nourriture
la cigarette va par l'usure et l'alcool
ça va tout d'un coup
mais si si par exemple on a un gars qui
boit je sais pas moi ces deux verres de
vin par jour il s'en portera pas plus
mal conclut que je trouve que après même
même eu des malaises à tout le monde et
plus particulièrement quand on est dans
quelque chose qui bouge comme la voiture
ont détruit comme ça on a beaucoup mieux
géré par pourquoi comment on perd lui
peut fumer dans la voiture on comprend
dans la dans la bouche et qu'on avait la
fumée ça apporte de la nicotine et de
goudron dans le dans les poumons puis
après on a des cancers par mois des
cancers du cas des cancers
cardiovasculaires parce que dans la
cigarette à ce n'est pas là le tabac en
tant que tel qui est nocif mais c'est la
famille mon père fut mais des fois la
fumée me donne
a des goûts et des fois j'ai je lui dit
d'arrêter de fumer mais en vain ou
l'ordi mais pas par accoutumée bouzid on
n'organise pas encore des années à vivre
et puis ils disent si seulement j'avais
plus jamais commencé vous savez que dans
certains pays en norvège par exemple il
ya une loi qui interdit la vente du
tabac au moins de seize ans en nouvelle
zélande aussi aux moins de 15 ans qu'est
ce que vous en pensez ce que vous pensez
que c'est bon ça peut être bon parce que
c'est souvent quand on commence très
jeune que l'on continue à fumer
ici c'est beaucoup meilleur à mon avis
de s'arrêter de son plein gré plutôt que
de se sentir contraindre d'arrêté moi je
pense qu'une information si elle est
vraiment bien faite elle est beaucoup
plus bénéfique qu'une interdiction
[Musique]